let's go next to our caller from the two
six two area code who's calling today
from two six two hey is that me yes it
is hello oh hey mouthing all right it's
great to talk to you so you recently did
a segment about how the Democrats might
have a chance of getting to the Senate
right yes all right so I noticed in that
you never talked about possibly getting
rid of Mitch McConnell but you have
talked about that race before do you
think that you have a chance I mean it's
a big uphill battle the reason I didn't
include it is it's it is a long shot and
I get that Amy McGrath is raising some
good money but if I'm you know I want to
push that as much as I can to try to get
McConnell out but at the same time if
I'm gonna do a serious analysis of like
the five seats that are most likely to
be taken back admit or even the seven
seats most likely to be taken back Mitch
McConnell's seat is not one of those
five or seven all right yeah it is sad
okay that's really all I had to ask all
right Matthew from Milwaukee appreciate
the phone call thank you oh sorry yes
okay now he's gone all right that's it
four calls today it has been a very very
rough day with the with the call system
something something is very there's must
be something going on with the we've got
like gremlins in the system or something
like that I think I've got the wrong
type of wire or tube connected so we
will try to deal with that for next week
that's it for today quick break audience
questions coming up next